est l'une des caractéristiques de l'autisme sont
les sensibilités sensorielles
G1
[Musique]
et parfois il n'y en a pas ici dans le corps
tolère j'ai même un fait sans le
parfois elle revient avec ses amis
sont toujours agréables à regarder
mes mignonnes et je ne me sens pas comme ça
si belle pourquoi je ne pouvais pas regarder
pas parce que je ne voulais pas mais je n'avais pas
pas de vêtements confortables
ce jour-là pour habiller les touches que nous
peut faire mal et les vêtements peuvent arriver le
même par exemple des étiquettes ou des coutures
peut nous gratter dire qu'ils ressemblent
comme des aiguilles perçant le chapeau EA
certaines textures que je ne peux pas
toujours regarder les paroles coller les vêtements
très " G1
[Musique]
ET là
Bonjour est votre mère de Albergaria Solaris
toujours à la mode et créateur d'Infinit
Collection pour les amis donc c'était trop
un processus très découverte de
étude de recherche écouter la région de Raquel
de la voix de l'artiste essayant de comprendre
quels étaient exactement les besoins qui
ils se sont sentis en la première personne à recevoir
exactement quel était le vrai
le besoin de vêtements est alors apparu
ici la question d'essayer de comprendre aussi
ce qui a déclenché la surcharge ou
par surstimulation
sensoriel et qu'il n'y aurait pas tant que ça
Le niveau de Tatu mais que la personne apprend
quand tu es dans la rue il y en a plusieurs autres
symboles qui peuvent également déclencher le
ces surcharges et je ne peux pas le supporter
un long moment entre un magasin du centre
commercial parce que nous regardons tous
généralement la résolution très forte la
la musique sonne aussi
J'aime qu'Aline entre dans un magasin
et voir tout ce gâchis
déréglementé alors j'ai essayé
imaginer
les morceaux qui étaient aussi un presque comme
un cas où ceux qui sont autistes à la maison
vous pouvez vous réfugier dans votre chambre ou même
tu peux aller sans vêtements si ça te dérange mais
dans la rue et il n'est pas possible qu'il soit passé
pour la partie de fabrication de la pièce ainsi que
si c'était une couverture comme si c'était une maison
où Beyond Impact organise
aussi se battre à propos de ce qui est une partie de ce qui est
visuel puis il est venu ce
possibilité par exemple dans ce pull
dans lequel qui a beaucoup beaucoup
destinations réussies peuvent tirer de
et cachez la partie des yeux comme
la bouche et le nez Si vous le laissez ou
beaucoup d'informations
discrètement aujourd'hui Bélier au sein du
les vêtements ou dans le cas des manches peuvent être
facilement
se réfugier et revenir à nouveau
pouvoir se déplacer et pouvoir communiquer avec les
la main d'abord cette jambe de chaleur est super
perso car je n'en ai pas de petits et le
les coutures sont il n'y a pas "a em
prise en compte de nos besoins
être la seule chemise qui a une balle
modeste haut en large et quand nous sommes
Nadia surchargée, on a remonté le col
étape dans les oreilles et nous obtenons plus
calmer
dans cette situation la pièce parfaite ne sera jamais
existe précisément parce que la condition
l'autisme est un spectre ou quoi que ce soit
travailler pour une personne ne sera pas
travailler pour un autre pull qui va
être bon pour ceux qui veulent se cacher
peut ne pas être bon pour ceux qui ont
difficulté à avoir trop de tissu autour
du cou seulement pour se sentir étouffé
ET là
[Musique]